new medical research shows that men and
women have different food cravings men
preferring meat and women preferring
sweets scientists trace this back to
caveman days when men had to go out and
hunt for food while women sat on their
fat asses eating chocolates
[Applause]
i was on a plane
last year okay going from new york to
l.a okay
and
me and my girlfriend were one side of
the plane there was the aisle
and the other side there were these two
huge fat women okay proper proper proper
fat one of them just got on and went can
i have a bow extension yeah of course
you can you've earned it right so
proper in fact i was thinking of calling
the pilot out and going should one of us
swap with one of them otherwise
we're just going to canada do you know
what i mean
[Applause]
and one of them was even fatter than the
other one okay
and she was there and she got on the
plane with one of those takeaway
buckets of fast food [ __ ] it
i mean there's your first clue when did
that happen when did fat people just
give up when did they go into a shop and
go i'll [ __ ] it just treat me like a
farmyard animal really
give me it in a bucket in fact just
strap it to my [ __ ] head and i'll
just
a bucket
really you want your meal in a bucket
yes
all right so
she's there and she's chowing down right
and i swear she turns to her fat friend
and says
this is the best fried chicken i've had
all day
one girl she was so fat she got the
scale a card came out said one at a time
i mean fat i mean she was on a richard
simmons show jumping up and down my tv
fell off the stand
when i'm talking with a fat girl you
know what i mean
big girl you're kidding she was standing
alone a cop told her break it up you
know
my girlfriend's gained a little weight
she said will you leave me i said yes
because i found you not fat
and if you get fat see getting a girl
who's already fat is different from
watching your girl become fat it's like
buying an old car is vintage watching
your car get old
get rid of that piece of mess it's got
miles on it unless somebody else call it
vintage sneaker analogy it's not vintage
if you watch it become old you have it
when it's from new to old that is just a
raggedy piece of garbage you know what
give the vintage to the chinese people
that want your old knights
do you understand what i'm saying my
girl is saying to me would you you're
going to le i'm like i'm not mature
enough because i am with you
because you're a hot girl if you become
not hot you become a fat girl then i can
go get a fat girl who functions being a
fat girl so when your sneakers get old
throw them away
oh what we doing the hood is you hang
them over the telephone line yeah what
would i do to my girl if she gets too
fat fat wife won't let me work out
there's nothing funnier than just
getting to the point what and just being
the truth i don't even want to hear the
question i just love like the
i mean that's like a one-liner
fat life won't let me work out i love it
that's one of the greats
of all time
questions hey there billy goat uh let's
see here uh i have a problem and would
like your hilarious opinion on what i
should do me and my wife have been
together about five years now and
married for two when we first got
together i was a young stud in my prime
in shape and crushing ass
left and right she was in good shape too
i used to work out four to five days a
week and life was great when we got
married she didn't like me going to the
gym because she says i will leave her
for a fitness check
uh the insecurity all right i got uh i
got to the point where i had
to get her a membership so we could go
together just so i could have my joy of
pumping iron
uh but she only went four times and
stopped going pumping iron
pumping iron you got to do it this guy's
an old school guy pumping iron people
still say why he was probably yeah he
says it you know
you know doesn't uh doesn't some of your
older relatives call people jive turkeys
huh
ah
do i gotta watch ghost dog go [ __ ]
leave my shoes on the stairs whatever
the [ __ ] that means
what does that [ __ ] mean i just love
i gotta i gotta tell you so i gotta tell
you something
as a comedian random but as a comedian i
respect the balls of an obscure
reference
she probably got offended me like what
because it's it's bill cosby we all saw
the [ __ ] movie you think i saw every
black movie that's out there
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i think she's just maybe she's really
into movies and she's [ __ ] offended
that you think that you know that she
would go watch that pile of [ __ ] oh my
god all right so anyways now we just had
a baby now we just had a baby girl
congratulations and we're both tired and
out of shape i want to get back into the
gym and get rid of this dad bod but i
can't because she guilt-trips me saying
i could help with the baby instead
uh instead of wanting to get in shape
also she always says i'm going to get
ripped and leave her for a skinny girl
in the gym and it annoys the [ __ ] out of
me that is annoying
yeah but you feel really insecure like
after you have a baby because it's just
your body it's like you they don't
prepare you
for what
birth does to your body i know but she
was doing this [ __ ] before
right but she's like moving out but no
i'm not saying that she shouldn't he
should
they should get a babysitter
so she can work out so they can work out
together or whatever yeah but he already
tried that and she only went four times
so now like you know listen
i've lost three friends this year two
heart attacks and a stroke like what
this guy's doing is actually
like
gonna prolong his life yeah you know you
don't want to have a kid with the guy
and then he drops of a [ __ ] heart
attack i mean what are we doing here
um
anyways instead of wanting to get in
shape
uh
okay i read all of that what should i do
i don't want to give up working out but
i also don't want to feel
be i feel unsupportive as a husband keep
up the good work congrats on the baby
boy i mean
his heart's in the right place go to the
[ __ ] gym that's really hard and you
know what though you have to go to the
gym though because it's what you feel
what makes you feel good and like she'll
get over it she won't take it purse just
like just have her blow you before you
go to the gym and she can relax what
that's a good no you just give her extra
kisses and tell her she's beautiful and
tell her she's a great mom and you'll
help her out like whenever she needs it
and she'll get over it like she should
no no take your dick out be like do you
want to hang on to this huh
you see this see this this is gonna walk
right out that door if you don't let me
go to jail
[Music]
i think they're going to have a few
bigger girls in this issue too yeah well
yeah really nice bigger girl like a
latifah on that you know no actually
great hummus in there
ashley green oh she's a real pig
i don't know who that is i'm joking but
he said bigger girls
i don't know who that is i don't think
she took that one well
she's a real pig
she's a bit on the big side okay but
she's nice that's a little little she's
likely for me yeah
yeah you can tell when you slap but it
rolls for a week
stop it
wait i can't with you guys i'm joking
i'd love to eat her out my mom's calling
me
all right so i mean
but good for her you want every guy you
don't want every guy going yeah that's
you know that's that's great but see i
don't
what bothers me is all right we all have
to accept this hey she's hot yeah yeah
but if a guy who's 5'4 comes in
everybody makes fun of them you know we
got to have it both ways how come the
5'4 guy can't get any love
all right
thanks for the support fellas
all right so we got chunky gals that's
we gotta high five her but how about the
bald guy nothing i think where does it
end let's see the 58 geezer
geezer yes oh
god
what i didn't see that coming at all
i like i think it looks amazing oh
you're lying
i like the the chest freckles the face
i was in with the face i'll be honest
with you she's got a nice body but then
the uh you don't like the bot the pull
out i mean it's it's like
she looks like a lady to see at the the
ramada pool
i'm not gonna i'm not against that
you do notice that they you know shot
her at the end of the day when the sun
was going yeah
where does it end are we gonna go
wheelchair you know
there has to be some standard is all i'm
saying yeah all women are beautiful well
i mean come on
that doesn't make sense
in different ways the definition of the
word beautiful means there's only a few
you know sports illustrated i gotta say
uh the swimsuit issue is probably the
the only magazine i i still buy yeah
yeah
no i'm serious it's probably the only
one i still buy well you can collect
them you know i'm not a perv i don't
need to collect them right i'll take
that too sticky that's the problem
shots fired most models don't